let's go next to um let's go to jonathan
from arkansas jonathan welcome
i'm a hello can you hear me yes i can
um yes um i was i had a question about
the arkansas governor race um
as it looks it looks uh here living in
arkansas that sarah huckabee
sanders is will probably be the
will probably win the governor race it
does look that way
and uh
you know i do not want her to win at all
right i was just wondering if you have
uh any advice because
uh if you you think
i should go forth uh
for
for the
the republican washburn or if i should
just uh because voting for a democrat
will be uh
a vote thrown away uh here in arkansas
because i do not think chris jones will
will be able to beat the republicans
well but hold on a second sarah huckabee
sanders earlier this week won her
primary so she's going to be on the
ballot and then jones the democrat will
be on the ballot but you're saying there
will be another republican on the ballot
in november as well
uh
yes
oh why that doesn't make sense to me
is it a write-in campaign or something
oh no no never mind uh i was talking
about the
libertarian
oh libertarian listen vote for whoever
you agree with on the most okay that
that's my advice to you uh you can
decide in terms of the strategic aspect
of who to vote for but i would just tell
you vote vote for whoever you agree with
the most because quite frankly it just
seems like sarah huckabee sanders is
going to blow out the wind you know
yeah yeah sadly sadly
sadly
yeah i mean
and if do you think there's anything i
could do or do you think is is uh that's
the reality no listen i mean i i don't
think it's worth giving up she should be
challenged as much as possible if she's
going to win make her spend as much
money as possible to win make it as
difficult as possible for her to win so
i would figure out do you prefer the
democratic or the libertarian candidate
you can phone bank you can get involved
you can door knock it make it as hard
for her as possible and we have to
recognize it's an uphill battle because
arkansas is such a red state yes
yes uh all right david uh i'll let you
go uh thank you for taking my call
all right thank you jonathan from
arkansas yeah it's a tough uh
tough situation there all right thank
you to everybody who called in we are
not going to be able to speak to anyone
else today but we will speak to more
people again we'll go to a quick break
and be back right after this
i love documentaries and i bet many of
you do as well and for documentaries i
go to curiositystream one of our
sponsors it's an app for your phone
tablet tv like netflix or hulu except
curiositystream has a way better
selection of documentaries because
curiositystream only has documentaries
that's what they specialize in if you
are looking for the new award-winning
documentary they have it if you're
looking for classic documentaries they
have those they have a ton of great
original content always adding more to
the catalog i just watched
zenith which is about the latest
advancements in space travel a topic i'm
super interested in but there's
documentaries about just about every
topic imaginable i've been a curiosity
stream subscriber for several years now
it's my favorite app on my roku and the
best part of curiosity stream it's 15
bucks a year
at curiositystream.com
pacman and the link is down below